now if you look carefully you'll notice
that political and media leaders on the
Left are slowly chipping away at this
idea of masculinity in other words what
it means to be a man don't believe me
we'll check out this discussion of
school shooters on MSNBC who's been told
to man up what does that mean
no sir no emotion yeah what's the
hardest part about growing up for boys
hiding the pain yeah not being able to
express yourself oh my word so the
problem is masculinity and targeting it
isn't reserved for less left-wing cable
shows here's former President Obama a
lot of our problems are caused by old
men no offense
men world exactly a spring chicken I
mean come on let's discuss this bring in
Liberal analysts I'll not call you
liberal analyst Julie you're an analyst
who happens to be a little liberal yeah
to debate you could call me left-leaning
I would say oh let's talk about this
like when I hear these attacks on
masculinity I I hear the left equating
masculine what what it means to be
masculine with abusive or criminality no
we're all against abuse we're all
against criminality at least we should
be if we're not you're weird so for me
when you're someone that you say
someone's masculine it doesn't I don't
see that or no of course I don't want
that and most no one I know wants that
but it's okay for a man to as a friends
of mine say protect provide and defend
and I'm sorry most women I happen to
know like men who like to do that that
they carry themselves that way and
that's what they think their role is
today in schools and in discussions like
we saw on MSNBC that's considered kind
of icky that whole construct is is
oppressive why is that well I think that
there's nothing necessarily wrong with
you know a man who wants to protect and
defend I think that what that specific
BC segment was talking about is the fact
that rigid gender roles specifically in
boys are tied to higher rates of suicide
substance abuse violence so it's
basically saying that these gender roles
are creating an environment in which men
feel that they men and boys feel that
they can't express themselves what's
what but Julie how is that connected
gender I mean we've had gender roles for
I don't know millennia so so we're like
well gender roles are causing boys to
commit suicide well maybe there's a lot
of societal factors involved in drug
abuse in promiscuity and shaming in
substance abuse of other types
addictions of violent video games
isolation because of social media
family dissolution you know what men
have been tending to be masculine for a
long long time right and I think the
members like well it's the masculinity
causing them to do all that I I think
that in the in the feminist community
you know you hear a lot of talk we talk
a lot about how gender roles tend to
hold women back but there's also
something that needs to be discussed
about how gender roles tend to hold men
back so men are taught from a young age
from very very young age preschool age
that they're supposed to be unemotional
that they're supposed to be macho that
they're supposed to be aggressive and
because of that they don't really have
healthy valves for you know an outlet of
their anger frustration thinks they're
feeling sensitive about rage thinks
they're experiencing in schools and
because of that it expresses itself
often and yes there are certainly other
factors at play here but it often
expresses itself through violence and
through you know turning inward through
depression through self harm through
substance abuse and I'm not saying that
it's the only cause I feel like they're
all predators I mean I mean I know a lot
of guys who work in a workplace
maybe it's lawyers or businessmen and
they feel like it's open season on them
I mean these are good people I feel like
we can't compliment anyone we got to be
careful what was it and they feel like
literally if they're 25 and single they
can't ask out you know a gal down the
hallway for a drink because if they do
that's going to be considered somehow
overly aggressive or
view civ I'm telling you I it's not easy
to be a man in the current work
environment or in the current societal
involvement Wow I would argue it's it's
a lot harder to be a woman in the
current work environment in the current
you know that's that's a given right so
you know I think that perhaps these men
are experiencing additional pressure
they're having to watch what they say
watch how they behave I think that
that's a welcome change after the way
that women have long been treated in the
workplace so well I wouldn't say that
that's one of the root causes of these
increased self harming and violent
behaviors and men I think that gender
roles play play a part in that and all
the things that that come with these
gender roles create isolation they
create anger and we go I'm sorry we're
gonna go run the black but great segment